from Warner Brothers Studios in
Hollywood it's the Conan of E&C Awards
celebrating excellence in the sitting
and looking arse here now is your
thank you very much this is exciting
thank you
this is a really great night and you
know what for a night this important I
think I need to dress the part Bruce if
you don't mind there we go
thank you very much yeah okay and first
of all this is the audience II award
that you stand a chance of winning if
you get an audience II and what a
beautifully crafted sculpture that is
woman not only not only are there no
genitals but there's actually a scoop
where the genitals would be which
reflects my own condition
[Laughter]
was an accident in the fifth grade but I
keep loose change there now that's not
the point that's not the point at all
we've got the audience the awards where
we pay tribute to the most important
people the studio audience and let's get
into it
our first audience award is for the best
impression of a celebrity in the
audience e goes to the person in seat 5d
for their impression of rapper Ludacris
this next audience award is also for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
16e for their impression of Marcy from
peanuts
[Music]
[Applause]
Vanessa audience the award is also for
best impression and the audience egos to
the person in seat 12d for their
impression of a hydrogen bomb
[Music]
the next audience egos the person in
seat 12l it's the award for the audience
member most likely to be the husband and
a paper towel commercial who says honey
I made a mess again
next audience he goes to two audience
members it's the award for the couple
most likely to invite you over to help
break in the new hot tub
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah the next audience e also goes to
two people it's the award for the couple
that accepted the offer to help break in
the hot tub and then things got pretty
crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that second guy he was like yep it's
going down our neck that's the ghost of
the person in seat 15 see it's the award
for the audience member whose inner
thoughts are just recipes for chili okay
yeah okay what you do first you take a
pound and a half of ground beef I prefer
70% lean you Brown that in the pan and
then you add a little chili powder
already pretty scoop tomatoes because
it's pretty much all I'm thinking about
now too
one tradition at major award shows is
fawning over industry legends who no one
has ever heard of now I will not be
wasting anyone's time with that kind of
nonsense but I do want to take just a
moment to welcome someone in our
audience I can't believe he's here
ladies and gentlemen the great Italian
sound editor
Leonardo las Casas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our next audience egos to the person
sitting in seat 17 our it's the audience
member who's wearing a large hat that is
ruining the show for people behind them
but everyone feels too guilty to ask him
to remove it
[Applause]
our next award goes to the audience
member in seat 42k it's the audience
member who was traveled here from the
future to warn his present self that
something terrible is about to happen
you're about to appear in a terrible
comedy bit on a stupid show cover your
face
[Music]
that was going pretty well
and finally we couldn't do this show
without some terrific sponsors Andy tell
us about tonight's sponsor tonight's
audiences are brought to you by Mama's
little helper pregnancy coolers Mama's
little helper pregnancy coolers it's the
easy way to smuggle booze into
high-security sporting and entertainment
events then when you're safely in your
seat deliver your joy to the world
available in three sizes first second
and third trimester great for beer
bellies - I guess my water broke Mama's
little helper you've got a bun in the
oven and it's ice-cold what a horrible
idea
Kevin Nealon sears stick around
[Applause]
you